si vous êtes d'accord pour passer
attaquant quelques instants chez renault
damien abad de le vice président des
républicains était ce matin sur ses news
et le moins qu'on puisse dire est que
lui aussi était plutôt sévère c'est le
symbole de la déconnexion du pouvoir
avec les français aujourd'hui beaucoup
de français vont partir en vacances ils
attendent leurs horaires du vol charter
ils ont l'impression que finalement on
vit pas dans le même monde et c'est
aussi le symbole de l'arrogance du
pouvoir vis-à-vis des français parce que
et leur fils ne s'impose pas lui même
c'est qu'ils imposent aux autres on a
voté une loi de moralisation de la vie
politique
on a encadré les frais des députés et
force est de constater que ce que l'on
impose aux députés on n'impose pas
forcément miss au premier ministre je
trouve que c'est regrettable et surtout
les conditions et la manière dont ça
s'est fait avec 60 personnes qui ont
changé d'avion en cours de route voilà
il changeait de l'avion puisqu'en fait
ils sont allés avec un avion de l'état
de lever que le dernier à tokyo et c'est
à ce moment là qu'ils sont montés dans
l'avion
louez renaud girard êtes vous choqué par
tout cela
j'avais compris que pour une raison qui
m'échappe
l'avion militaire effectivement est
arrivé vide à roissy deux heures après
l'avion qui ont été loués qui est arrivé
ils n'ont qu'à paris mais pour permettre
au premier ministre assiste et conseille
de défendre autre chose importante parce
que pris dans la république lui-même
partait en voyage juste après donc cette
voie là on a les rives a divisé les deux
langues il fallait assurer laconique du
talent donc ça c'était sans doute peut
être une raison suffisante pour faire
cette dépense se dépense importante je
crois pas affectivement d'abord je crois
pas que edouard philippe
et c'est là jadallah prémunissent
extrêmement chargé c'est pas lui qui
s'occupe de ceux de ces détails de
logique il n'a pas le temps et c'est un
peu normal c'est pas son boulot derrière
de voilà le et
et donc je suis d'accord qu'il faut pas
faire dans le populisme
ceci dit c'est vrai il ya un problème
est un problème en france général de
train de vie de l'état et aussi de
l'autre jour je suivais en scout est une
sorte de deux voitures c6 qui a brûlé un
feu rouge avec une sonnerie deuxième la
police j'y tiens je savais pas quel
commissaire de police avaient des
cécités des grandes citroën comme ça et
il sait il s'est arrêté devant le
restaurant lasserre et d'été 12h30 et en
est sorti un ancien premier ministre
pour aller déjeuner ne voulait pas être
en retard visiblement oui qui s'était
permis de brûler le feu rouge
et là je me suis arrêté en scooter et g
/ ints et al
les flics sont venus vers moi ouais
monsieur je dis je suis renaud girard du
figaro et vous allez bientôt entendre
parler de moi c'est déjà calmé tout de
suite d'ailleurs voilà la came to il ya
effectivement un problème pas en
l'espèce parce que il faut il faut voir
eagle l'a très bien dit et je te brosser
pas qui exactement pays peut-être que
les hommes d'affaires payé leur billet